good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Thursday
it's your girl La turia herdia me
clardia literally messages every day hey
litterd and like the way your nicknames
catch on is frightening they are just
contagious but how do you feel about
being the turd
because you know what like I feel like
sometimes I take a nickname too far and
someone's like please stop calling me
that I'm like okay okay I I nickname too
close to the Sun
I am not bothered in the least because
one thing about me I'm just happy when
people are talking to me you know and
about here what they're calling me you
know yeah okay great to know yeah
um I'm like first of all today's
Thursday it feels like a Wednesday
because yesterday I [__] up you know
what I was a negligent podcaster I
forgot to select the deer toasters but I
got them today and they're really good I
picked them yesterday and I've actually
been thinking about a few of them since
yesterday because they're they're like
conundrums damn I don't know what I'm
gonna even suggest okay we'll talk
through it we'll keep it out and I know
you chose the stories today and I know
you definitely did not choose this story
I don't even know if it's like been made
into like a news article yet but I
wanted to fill you in on like something
like major that's going on on Tick Tock
that is
causing interesting conversation okay
let's do it no nothing of my stories is
underground Tick Tock news I don't know
if this is like for everyone but like my
entire for you page is talking about
this and like it's just insane okay so
it revolves around the girl Michaela we
spoke about her a few weeks ago she's a
makeup artist she had a scandal a few
months ago when she was like try being
an influencer for a day it was a little
out of touch but like what should we do
kill her
um she has found herself embroiled in
another Scandal she posted in Instagram
no sorry a tick tock ad yesterday I
would say like 10 or 15 big gurus posted
an ad for this new L'Oreal mascara okay
and to be honest like a lot of the ones
that I saw like bretman rock like people
who just put the mascara on like it
wasn't that compelling of stuff like it
just looked like a mascara
um but Michaela was doing you know she
had one eye on already and she was like
let me show you she did a cone she's
like okay now I'm gonna go in with the
second coat and when she did the second
coat it was fairly obvious she was
wearing like lash extensions or like
lash false lashes that's it sorry thank
you and at first the comments were like
Michaela like be [__] for real like
this is not the the mascara and then of
course it just [__] spiraled you know
she's untrustworthy she's greedy she's
dishonest she's you know abusing her
platform spiraling into like an actual
Scandal the she went silent for the rest
of the day the video has 14 million
views which just to put into perspective
she has 14 million followers yeah so
like that's insane well you said me will
you send me the video right now because
I have some thoughts but I just want to
watch it I don't want to like
it's worth mentioning that
um she was in the comments at the
beginning like she's been silent But
like after an hour you know the post
went up she was responding to comments
saying she was not wearing false lashes
oh okay so she was she's maintaining
she's maintaining that she's not wearing
the lashes oh okay I was about to defend
her even wearing lashes
um okay so I made a tick tock last night
that's like blowing up and people are
like roasting me in the comments but
like I stand by what I said because in
my opinion is she wearing false lashes
yes okay let me watch this quickly yeah
you don't need sound you'll see when you
know they go from lashes to false lashes
give Jackie a minute she's watching the
dog I'm watching the talk you guys you
can go to at Michaela as well no Guerra
she is we're getting a live reaction so
so far she's putting it on the second
eye yeah and everything looks good okay
then she says she's gonna go in for
another coat and she'll show you the
final product she's gonna go in for
another coat on her second eye is what
she's gonna do because you won't let me
yep oh oh oh okay
and then like when she shows the final
product
oh I guess
huh I'm not convinced I can see how
people could say that but it's not to me
it's not glaringly obvious but I just
want to say two things like one there's
a chance that she really is not wearing
lashes and this is amazing for the
mascara there's a scandal that people
really think she's wearing lashes two
when lash commercials are on television
they always have the model wearing false
lashes it says really small underneath
that you know the lashes have been
enhanced that this is not actually the
mascara so like how is this different of
an advertising practice also like you
can wear false lashes and wear mascara
with it too like okay I'm doing my
lashes my makeup for the day like this
is what my lashes look like you should
because influencers are are successful
for their authenticity and that's why
people follow influence influencers you
should be honest about that if that's
what you're doing but like it's not
crazy to wear mascara and lashes and
it's not unheard of to wear Lashes in a
mascara ad it's every day on TV you see
that
so did you see my Tick Tock I literally
said the exact same thing I said like
they're doing National commercials like
this that are so misleading when you see
like a Pantene commercial their hair is
digitally altered they're wearing
extensions like we are constantly being
duped and it's like this bar we have for
influencers and not like National
commercials and the comments were like
well they disclose I okay I'm sure that
they do are you getting up close to the
TV and reading it no it's like it's
subliminal messaging and so the way
people are attacking Michaela and so
overall the people who are you know
against Michaela are like but she lied
and okay let's say she did lie we don't
know for sure because we really don't
have any full proof that she's wearing
lashes but let's say she did lie
okay what should we do should we go to
our house a killer like
okay she lied like
what are you gonna do she probably
didn't think it was gonna blow up and to
be this big thing it was like an ad I
thought people would move on I just it's
like people getting so like it's the
chronically online syndrome yeah like
like it's about that the only part of
the lying to me that is like problematic
just because influencers are have their
platform and they get ads because
they're genuine and authentic like
that's the difference between being an
influencer and being a commercial model
or whatever like you're putting your
whole chest behind something like so
the fact that she would say in the
comments still that she wasn't wearing
them that's where it's a little dicey if
it is a lie but overall the idea that
she is promoting this mascara she made
the mascara look as best as she could
and like you can wear mascara and lashes
and like this is my final look
it's a little misleading shirt but like
it's a gray area that's advertising
watch Mad Men like they're they're here
to sell a product no and that's where
influencer culture gets so toxic because
it's the entitlement from fans being
like we gave you this career we bought
that house for you she's getting married
like we are paying for your wedding it's
like calm down like first of all you
don't have to follow anyone this is a
totally free country you are more than
welcome to unfollow someone if you
disagree with something they're doing
but like I hate that part of influencer
culture where it's like the it's an
entitlement from an audience where it's
like Michaela is Michaela because of
Michaela it's what she has built it's
what she's created and like it's the way
people take responsibility for the
success of influencers that kind of is
like what gives them this attitude where
like they can just comment on anything
going on in an influencer's life and
people might disagree with me that's
totally fine like personally just based
on my life experience like more often
than not I'm going to side with the
influencer because I do feel like you
know in a lot of ways influencers are
misunderstood
um and I think people are really hard on
influencers and I always wish like you
know the internet and just people in
general would give energy to things that
actually matter not whether or not you
know Michaela's wearing lashes right and
like actual false advertising like
things that are actually misleading like
people doing what Michaela's might be
doing but like on a much larger scale me
reading I'm reaching a much larger
audience like use your outrage for
things that are actually harmful just
like you were saying someone commented
disgusting on your ins on your Tick Tock
it's like such an overstatement human
trafficking is disgusting right like
let's not be dramatic okay let's just
not forget it's literally mascara yeah
but I I understand like the the scrupled
premise of like of course when you are
an influencer like you're you're there
to be authentic especially her I've seen
some of her videos like she's all she's
very open and wrong some influencers are
extremely curated and like we don't want
to see the behind the scenes we want to
see the Perfection but like it doesn't
seem like she's that way she starts
she's pulled back the curtain yes so I
understand like the
um desire for 100 authenticity but I
also understand that she's running a
business and she's selling a product and
I'm gonna make the product look as best
as possible and I'm allowed to wear
lashes when I'm wearing mascara
100 100
I don't know I'm just not gonna like be
over here crying unfollowing like
petitioning for her life to be destroyed
because maybe she lied in a comment like
girl I'm lying multiple times a day
about [__] that doesn't matter and
mascara doesn't [__] matter and
like if she lies in it if she lied then
now you know that and like maybe take
what she says with a grain of salt next
time but like
you don't have to Riot in the streets no
and a lot of the discourse is like you
know she's influencing you know people
who like shouldn't be spending ten
dollars on a mascara to buy a mascara
and it's like once again the
conversation that we're always having it
comes down to personal accountability
it's like if you're so easily
influencing you're not really looking
into the things that you're purchasing
well maybe that's something you need to
work on yeah
I just thought it was really interesting
conversation and there's actually really
nuanced debate going on on Tick Tock and
I've I've seen good takes on both sides
personally like I'm just I'm not going
to get into all get all bent out of
shape I could see how like if you go
down this Rabbit Hole like you are
extremely indignant about this because
like it's not scrupled like I could see
how you could get to that like place of
being really [__] mad about this but
you have to zoom out she wore lashes for
a mascara ad you have to zoom out and
then like if you want to then you have
to go you know you have to go in on
everything like on my Tick Tock Abby
Herbert the um tick tocker she commented
she was like I was a commercial model
and they would always write like model
wearing size small but like they were
actually tailoring the size small to fit
me perfectly right so that's misleading
right the back is all cinched when they
if they were to turn around it's full of
clips
so it's like
okay so we're going in on this why is
Michaela being the face of like this big
enormous thing that goes on in society
like why is she bearing the brunt of
like these billion dollar companies
being misleading yeah and the brunt of
like advertising and Mis branding right
so if we want to have that conversation
about global billion dollar companies
I'm so here for it I'll be first in line
to discuss it I'm not having this
discussion about one girl who lives in
Boston just doing her best I'm just not
no no that mascara I kind of want to try
it because even before she put the Lash
on like I thought it looked good yeah I
saw like a couple other people who just
did like really kind of basic reviews
and like it didn't people who have
similar lashes to me which is like
straight kind of thin not good lashes
you know
um I wasn't impressed but now I mean
this is the greatest marketing since you
know now I'm sure they're like [__]
their pants
um
they don't appreciate how major this is
that like everybody's talking about this
new L'Oreal mascara and like is it real
is it not because I I think there's a
possibility that that she's not wearing
lashes I was like actually I'm like you
know what I want to go get it like I
just said from the drugstore I have been
thinking of just trying it out like in
your own video
yeah I feel like I'll have a hard time
finding it throw on a Lash
nobody like that's mean and we're all
mocking Michaela like I've seen people
do that like it was me and no but you're
not my communicate you're making the
people who are bent out of shape about
it 100 once again people are not okay
yeah well thank you for that um update
in what's going on on Tick Tock I'm glad
people are spending their time wisely
and taking up her classes that really
matter 100 it's so it's so good because
the rest of the world is perfect so it's
great that now we can focus on these
small issues I completely agree
and that's what we're going to do here
at the toes we're going to focus on
bettering the world we have some really
good stories today like some they're a
little random but they're I'm excited
about them okay go to any human interest
you know twins mutating with twins not
twins mutating with twins though
um
There Was You know I almost went down
that way but there are some like
statistic news that I think you'll find
interesting data we love a list
data data
um that's fabulous I'm excited what did
I do yesterday that I can catch everyone
up on
literally nothing like my back was
hurting me all day
and I just laid on my couch and worked
for my couch because I was not okay yeah
and like that's crazy that you are on
your couch not even in your bed I know I
felt like maybe you know changing it up
would help my back yeah did it no I got
my period this morning sorry to be that
girl and that helped my back
okay
sorry I didn't mean to trigger you it's
okay because
one you can break all my rules if you
want you know like I love everything
that you say and do keep doing you and
two like the show really is about like
everything that's going on in their
lives so like if your period is ruining
your day you have to share that with the
class yeah like and I'm just saying like
I've been complaining about my back a
lot and I I think it was because it was
like the week leading up to my period
cool cool
and that's all there is
so not much new with me either work like
meetings meetings meetings yesterday
I finished my book three stars for
Hillbilly allergy glad that I read it
and glad that I finished it and glad I
can move on to the redheads book
oh yeah big things happening over at the
redheads Community oh always I mean it's
just the sweetest place on the Internet
it's like there's Michaela's comments on
Tick Tock and then there's the redheads
true and that's true and that's all
there is
and that's all there is like Imagine One
Day the redhead's getting backlash
I should see it I could see it yeah I
mean I've I've heard some complaints
people are always coming for the
Snapchat it's just doing her
[__] best they're coming like
there's a little bit of controversy and
negativity at the redheads it's only
natural it there is it's only natural
we're on the internet but we keep it we
are we we're on the internet and we are
us right but we keep our blinders on at
the redheads we will not let nothing
stop
promoting literacy
so sorry it can't slow us down horse
blinders on focusing on your art that's
really should be everyone's mentality
can't see the haters
oh so today is our final like kind of
classic episode of Live episode live
thank you Jackson Claude original recipe
because chimuro is a very special
interview episode it's about an hour
long uh we will be announcing who the
guest is today on our Instagram so make
sure you're following at the toast I'm
so excited I watched it again yesterday
just like re-inspiring myself you know
yeah
um we like made some clips I'm really
excited for everyone to see it and so
there won't be like pop culture but
there will be like I don't know a look
in word tomorrow which I think maybe we
could all use
damn
you're holding up a mirror
right that's what I'm doing okay well I
can't wait to watch can't wait for it to
drop can't wait to hear everyone's
opinions about Diane Sawyer by the way
you haven't seen it yet have you no I'm
gonna be sitting it on my TV
it still needs like two edits that's I
had to send back notes last night but oh
wow but when it's done no I'm being
really particular like I feel very
strongly about this you're passionate
I have passion what's better than that
nothing
um well I guess the Fast Five is better
than that for sure
and I think without further Ado did it
do we can get in to the two the fast
five stories that you do need to know oh
wow that was a lot today's episode is
brought to you by State Farm the State
Farm personal price plan helps you
create a plan that gives you options so
you get an affordable price and it comes
with lots of benefits like the coverage
you want a policy that helps cover
what's important to you and an
affordable price just for you so you
know how important it is to cater things
to your likings like it's so much easier
to make your own Taylor Swift playlist
um because for me you know I'm going to
lean heavily into the Evermore era which
in my opinion is an extremely
understated and underestimated era so
personalization personalization is a
huge part of Jackie and I's everyday
lives and that's how State Farm does it
they can personalize their plans
personalization means you have the power
to choose what you want to include and
leave out and what you don't it just
feels better that way and why shouldn't
insurance work like that too that's what
State Farm personal price plan is all
about you can choose to include options
like bundling your home and auto
policies and that means you'll get the
coverage you want at an affordable price
just for you in the end you'll have a
policy that gives you what you want
is there anything better than that no
like a good neighbor State Farm is there
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices do vary by state and options
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary but again call or
go to statefarm.com today and create
your State Farm personal price plan and
I've always wanted to say this like a
good neighbor State Farm is there truth
State Farm is there tell them Jax you
mean Jakey from State Farm
today's episode is also brought to you
by Missouri
so Missouri is kind of everything of the
sort it is a jewelry company that is
giving us things we actually need you
are building a gift list for Valentine's
Day coming up or you have a birthday an
anniversary Missouri is the perfect
place to go Missouri believes you don't
have to overspend to treat those that
you love most they design high quality
fine jewelry that you can live in and
style your way and this year they've
curated gift guides with something for
every budget and recipient from
responsibly sourced Diamond Hoops to
recycled 14 karat gold solid Rings they
offer in-store and virtual styling
sessions for expert gifting and stacking
advice and 60-day returns during the
holidays plus Missouri drops new Styles
every Monday so you're guaranteed to
find something unique for everyone on
your list or just treat yourself with
shiny gifts for everyone Missouri is
where wishlists come true simplify your
holiday shopping and go to missouri.com
that's
m-e-j-u-r-i.com I really like Missouri
because to be honest like I feel like
the pieces are not like really really
trendy they're more classic and they're
stuff that you can invest in because
they're made really well and you can
wear for a long time like I have
necklaces from Missouri that I don't
have to take off before I get in the
shower because they're made of like good
material and I find that so frustrating
like to take off those little tiny
little clasps like every night before
the shower it's just like too much work
for me
um and I've been wearing Missouri for a
long time I feel like I found out from a
jury when they did a collab with Lauren
Elizabeth all those years ago and I
still have a lot of the Rings they
really age really well because they're
made well so that's missouri.com
m-e-j-u-r-i.com if you want to get that
like dainty jewelry like gold jewelry
look like you know snatchers always
rocking my jury like that's where you
gotta go for it it's the vibe our first
story a little apology news we got a
couple apologies today Luke Bryan is
apologizing for his absurd rant about
Dustin Lynch so I can't believe you
haven't seen this it's like a tick tock
slice yeah so Luke Bryan had his crash
my Playa Festival recently and he was
announcing the lineup and next on stage
was Dustin Lynch and this is how he
introduced him
he said no one has drank more liquor no
one has vomited more no one has taken
more drugs no one has taken more IVs no
one has passed more STD tests than this
next gentleman
oh my God I like Tick-Tock went crazy a
little bit some people said it was
uncalled for another said they were
quote Beyond disappointed in what Luke
said calm down everyone I have to assume
that Luke and Dustin have like a real
close friendship so Luke then put out a
video saying Dustin Lynch is one of my
dearest friends on the planet
um no one respects him more than I do
and that night at crash my Playa my
introduction of him was complete sarcasm
those words that I use were so absurd I
figured everybody would take it as
sarcasm that said he acknowledged that
obviously some people were offended
about that he would joke about drinking
using drugs and taking STD tests he said
I spoke to Dustin I love him he and I
are all good and I apologize to anybody
that doesn't understand my humor and
sarcasm oh my God this is so dumb if he
owes an apology to anyone it would be
Dustin Lynch and if Dustin Lynch ain't
mad you don't need to be mad Tick Tock
user 19876-4432 you know literally and
like if this weren't joke like he
wouldn't say that like of course you
can't even make him a joke about a
friend like it's crazy you really have
to also just take into account the
environment it's like a country music
festival people are lit I think he was
probably trying to be funny trying to
rile up the crowd trying to like
humanize Dustin Lynch
grip that he's reading off of this isn't
televised he's just like talking [__]
about his friend
the bar for what people have to
apologize for these days is so crazy to
me I think this is funny and when I
heard this if even if I was there I
would just assume that the two of them
have a great relationship right first of
all it's like Luke's Festival he's not
going to have someone that's not his
best right and he's not gonna say that
about anyone that he's not close with or
that he doesn't know also if you know
Luke Bryan you know he's like a very
very nice person his actual his story is
incredible he adopted you know I forget
how many I'm gonna butcher this story
but I believe his
yeah his sibling or sibling-in-law
passed away the siblings-in-law passed
away these kids I'd forget if it was his
sibling or his wife's sibling they both
passed away Luke and his wife adopted
the kids they live with them treat them
as their own are raising them he's
extremely talented but also like amazing
person so if you know anything about him
if you watch American Idol he's like
Goofy and silly he's kind of this like
All-American boy like shut up okay he's
not like he's not a bad person yeah and
I'm sure the people at the festival like
thought it was hilarious like no one
thought anything but then you know it
gets on Tick Tock and it reaches like
all these people who would never be at
this Festival who don't know Dustin
Lynch and they're like this is beyond
disappointing
literally this is upsetting me that's
wrong Luke how could you that's
disgusting STDs is not something you
joke about in this country how dare you
how dare you so it's just like some
things just aren't for everyone no and
some things don't need to be explained
yeah
but I'm glad that he explained it
otherwise I don't know if this would
have been made news and it's just no
it's true made me chuckle no now I kind
of want to go to this Festival sounds
lit uh yeah I didn't know he does his
own festivals crash my Playa yeah and I
think they're in Mexico like they're
real big like spring break type parties
that's why it's called crash my Playa
yeah and doesn't he have a song about
aplaya
[Music]
um I'm sure he has a lot of songs about
like the beach yeah who doesn't right I
think no I actually think he has a song
called crash my plyo because like that
would make sense
like I don't think he does I think he
has a song called like
Play Play It Again
such a good song you know he doesn't
have a song called crash my Playa but
there's a playlist
I'm sure it's good yeah it's a good
playlist check it out
I didn't need this apology yeah moving
on okay next apology news the razzies
are apologizing as they should as they
should for nominating a 12 year old
actress for worst performance not cool
the razzies are walking back one of
their picks for the worst of the year
after backlash for selecting a 12 year
old actress earlier this week the
razzies and unaffiliated foil to the
Oscars that instead picked the so-called
worst movies of the year if you watch
the show you are very familiar with the
razzies announce the nominees for 2023
among the selections was Fire Starter
actress Ryan Kira Armstrong under the
category of worst actress which also
included Bryce Dallas Howard Diane
Keaton Caius godelario and Alicia
Silverstone people on social media
Express outrage over the organizers
nominating a child on its list they said
uh you know quote the razzies are run by
soulless people nominating a 12 year old
[__] them that child could grow to be
amazing if you haven't gotten it in
their head anyways okay that's not why
it's wrong I just want to say a
statement razzie's put out a tweet and a
statement uh the founder apologized and
said they will no longer nominate people
under 18. he called the outrage dialed
criticism that brought our attention to
how insensitive we've been in this
instance he said quote sometimes you do
things without thinking then you are
called out for it then you get it it's
why like literally that Perfection
straight facts it's he said it's why the
razzies were created in the first place
we have removed Armstrong's name from
the final ballot that our members will
cast next month we also believe a public
apology is owed to miss Armstrong and
wish to say we regret any hurt she
experienced as a result of our choices
okay I have to say them nominating a 12
year old is so wrong like it's so wrong
it's mean it's bullying kids should be
protected I completely agree with all
the backlash and I never agree with
backlash like I just they're totally
justified and I have to say I love this
response because I do feel like
sometimes it's happened to me sometimes
you just like do or say something and
you don't realize till somebody points
it out to you how [__] up it is like I
have definitely had that experience and
I really like this statement I do
forgive I feel like the razzies are all
in good fun but when it comes to kids
like kids should be left out of it and
they realize that I I love how this
whole situation turned out and now they
have the policy moving forward no one
under 18 will be nominated I think this
is great I think this is great too uh I
think everyone can relate to like doing
something you know not realizing what's
wrong with it and then getting it
instantly so I'm glad they apologize I'm
glad they put out this policy they don't
need to like cancel the razzies no they
made a mistake they're owning up to it
and they're making it right
and what I like is that the razzies like
it's always been in good fun it's really
never meant to be like mean yeah and you
know it's not like satirical and it's
not like they're going after like bad
movies that didn't make any money that
are like by nobodies it's like the Bryce
house Howard is also nominated for best
actress like she could take a joke no
that's what Joan River said you star on
a 25 million dollar picture I'm allowed
to make fun of your dress like it's all
in good fun
but you draw the line at kids yeah I
think that's so fair I think that's the
right line to draw I'm glad that they
were on it have they never nominated a
child
up until this point I guess not because
it's just the one that got backlash
I I don't know but I feel like if there
were if there was a history they would
have mentioned it right like I know
people would have given receipts like
this is the eighth time yeah constantly
bullying children yeah they have a
pattern a history yeah
um I just love the story I think I think
it's great I think it's a teachable
moment I think it's great PR I think how
razzie's handled this like a lot of
companies could could take a look at
this statement and think that's a good
example this should be in like a
textbook yeah agreed perfect
next up a little engagement news that I
found to be kind of low-key
Bachelor Alum Hannah Anne is engaged to
her NFL boyfriend I shot on Tick Tock
this morning and I thought it was
interesting too you saw the video she
posted no I just saw like a headline
shot yeah like got it well she announced
her Instagram to Indianapolis Colts
running back Jake funk in a sweet tick
tock on Wednesday her proposal featured
a Beachside dinner romantic candles and
a projection across the water that red
she said yes so The Tick Tock it looks
like a regular like date night you know
sponsored picnic dinner video like how
just Tick Tock Tings and then at the end
she shows her big honking ring
I like have I find Hannah Anne's like
trajectory to be really interesting I
haven't watched The Bachelor probably
like since her time and I do think like
long gone are the days of being able to
have like a really successful influencer
career I think like you know the Lauren
Lane Becca Tilly Amanda Stanton like
those days are over but there's a few
girls every now and then who sneak in
who aren't leads
but who
I think are gonna you know are doing
like actually really good meaningful
content influencers yeah who like people
Hannah G Hannah Anne like Tasha but
Tisha was a lead so it's like it's
almost unfair yeah and also Tasia was
still in like the era when yes people
like deeply cared but I still I mean I
have no idea what's going on with the
bachelor right now but every season like
there they still have a couple million
viewers a night like every season
there's like two or three breakout girls
who will end the season with a million
father followers no really I don't think
they will end with a million followers
not even Clayton
what was his name
Susie was the girl who won let's see how
many followers wait also Susie's a
toaster Susie is a toaster that I didn't
know 398.
C and she won so like the power of the
bachelor is not as big as it once was so
I'm always impressed when people in
recent years like really season was
still that was like pre-covered we were
so invested remember Barb like it was
yeah and then he proposed to Anna Anne
but he wanted Maddie and he's dating
Kelly like we were all there yeah we did
but I don't think a lot of those girls
yes they did Matt okay so Maddie took a
really interesting route to her
influencer she very much like embraced
and Dove deep into like the niche
Christian sermon kind of like Sadie
Robertson Southern Vibe yeah and she's
like a motivation uh like a a she's like
a pastor a past dress but she's not a
pastorous but it's true she's like um
like a Tony Robbins
yes yeah
so like that's really Niche I feel like
Hannah Anne is so interesting for me
because she's like she's reminding me
like of back in the day like Becca Tilly
Amanda Lauren like she's really killing
it and like there was like her man used
to play on the Rams and he won the Super
Bowl two years ago so like a year ago so
she was like like she's like killing it
I'm like happy for her because what my
thesis was no I know I know but I'm
telling you she still got in under the
wire of like I know I know that you just
like have to disagree with me on this
point she got in under the wire of like
when girls were still popping off that's
all I don't think so
I think so
okay I don't
anyways I didn't know that she like had
a man's I don't follow her but her stuff
comes up for me sometimes so I'll like
go and look what she's up to and she
does like her like cooking content yeah
um I didn't know that she had a serious
boyfriend that was in the NFL and then I
was like okay well I don't know how much
he plays but now you're saying he just
he won the Super Bowl she was at the
Super Bowl she was at the Super Bowl I
knew she had an NFL man because at the
Super Bowl she was like her content was
going better she's big on Tick Tock
she's really like a full cross-platform
influencer and I think she does really
well I think so too her boyfriend her
fiance looks so young like it's
but like that too they just look really
young but I'm really happy for them like
I love
I love love
and I love when two
young starlets get together
to see like attractive rich people
breeding with one another yeah like it
was like I'm happy and it's engaged and
I'm also happy it's to an NFL player 100
are you ready for our next story yeah
Emma Roberts is roasting herself and
revealing one of her biggest style
regrets from being a child actress even
though I think it's not warranted but
she Oh I thought you were gonna say
the other big news from her watch
weapons live appearance is she was asked
about Leah Michelle knowing how to read
oh I saw that no this this is from her
Vogue beauty secrets video oh she's
obviously on like a press tour right yes
because she has like a few movies coming
out um but she got very real about her
past style choices as someone who
started acting at age nine she's had a
lot of red carpet moments to think about
in terms of some of her most memorable
and not in a good way outfits she
recalled the 2001 red carpet for the
film blow where she wore a casual outfit
that she thought at the time was a real
winner she said I went to the store in
La Fred Siegel and I chose cargo capris
a sequin tank top and a purse made out
of tires that had beer caps on the side
and I just thought I arrived
she said I was in clogs I was like this
is my moment and I look back on that now
and I'm like she's so cute
um like she had no idea that was not
gonna hold up I just want to say the
picture of her in the outfit like she's
[__] slaying the outfit sounds worse
than it is it does it's not great but I
don't know I feel like for things like
that it's all about how you felt in the
Moment Like and she felt like a star she
felt like she'd arrived like I love that
for her I love this for her and also
like what is an 11 year old supposed to
wear on a red carpet that's like not
black tie like we don't need to see her
being like styled by style me Maeve like
right where you feel comfortable in
something age-appropriate age
appropriate it's definitely tough to be
like really young on red carpets like I
always find like when there's like every
now and then like a really young actress
or actor well not actor actress oh
excuse me after sneeze everyone are you
ready oh the power
of the sneezes compels her
um like I feel like once a year there's
like a really young kid at the Oscars
and if it's a girl like she's wearing
like a you know like a flower girl dress
and like a little purse it's really hard
to style someone that young because like
you don't want them to look like 15 yeah
I think them to look better I think it's
even harder to style them when it's not
the Oscars because for the Oscars like
they make dresses for 11 year old girls
and they're so cute and like No One's
Gonna say they're like baptism dresses
yes yes exactly but to like
direct like what do 11 year olds wear no
I don't know I literally don't know
I don't know especially like when Emma
Roberts is like kind of like a nepo baby
so there's like a cool factor to being a
nepo baby it's like you were raised in
this town you gotta look cool whereas
like if it's you know someone who's new
on the scene they're so cute and you're
just like oh look what she's wearing
yeah I think she looks cute she also
said in her defense it's not fair
because I was a child actor so I'm being
held to looks when I wore when I was 11
years old no it's so like I die we
literally last night me and you were
going to say yes we were just looking at
pictures of ourselves like in our phones
like on Google from like five years ago
and like the way I absolutely have to
pass away like it must happen
right now is safe yeah so imagine I have
to go that imagine those type of high
quality photos living on the internet
forever from when you were 11. I wore
brown Gaucho pants to school every
single day I feel like when you're 11
it's not as bad as like when you're like
I don't know 18 19 like you really think
you're doing something
11 is pretty bad too because what's
great about being 11 is like you don't
really have those the emotional
intelligence yet for like being
self-conscious or like insecure in your
body you know like you're not you
haven't like gone through puberty yet
you're just like okay you just think
it's closed on a body and that's like a
really healthy Mentor I like that color
with that yeah that's what I'll wear and
you don't really notice it like the
shirt pulls a little bit on your belly
like you don't notice those things
because you're young and you shouldn't
so it's almost it's definitely worse
yeah
but she looked so cute and it's just
funny it's also like crazy that she is
like the most stylish even though it's
actually not crazy because I don't think
there's like that many crazy bad looks
from her and like once she became a
young adult like it was the looks for
slaying
yeah when I think of like red carpet
photos that like come back and like we
look and I always think of Ashley
Tisdale I don't know why like I just
feel like I can remember like a million
yeah like those pictures of her wearing
like layered tank tops jeans yeah and a
belt
over the jeans and the car and a
cardigan that's like a shrug shrugs in
terms of like crazy for sure who had it
worse Emma Roberts is fine but I do love
this Vogue series of people going back
and looking at their most iconic moments
and their most like horrendous
cringe-tastic moments I just but like if
this is Emma Roberts most cringe like
she's
she's doing great
our fifth and final story are you ready
for it wow I feel like we breezed by
today we did but this one is really
interesting because American Kennel Club
has not announced the top Canine dog
names in 2022.
how interesting how fascinating so here
are the top girl dog names who actually
should we start with boys since like
we're boy dog moms sure
Number One Max
Maximilian Hilton room number two Milo
cute three Cooper it's like such classic
so basic for Charlie
King Charles five Teddy I think that the
adore
would fall under Teddy actually Teddy
would fall under Theodore but not me and
Theo being so influential but no I don't
think that you are actually because it
would be Theodore
I think people are naming their their
dogs Teddy
okay uh six Tucker that's dog classic
sorry if these are any of your kids
names but they are really similar to
popular kids names yeah seven buddy
it's cute I actually like that it is
cute eight bear I like that a lot yeah
nine rocky
okay
Rock Leo
Theo I think these are all cute names
these are also kind of popular human
names but not like the most popular
especially for boy human names A lot of
them are like very traditional like John
William it's different with girls but
they they don't get as many like trendy
names as girls do yeah that's true
um but still like Milo is such a popular
boy's name right now yeah as is Theodore
is Milo short for anything
not that I know of
okay I feel like sometimes popular dog
names then become popular human names
like that's what happened with Theo
like when you named him that it wasn't
crazy that you named your dog Theo but
now it's just like that's a gorgeous
human name no and actually I this is so
weird
I named Theo Theo
and I had only ever met one other Theo
in my whole life I didn't know anyone
else with that name I'd never heard that
name there was just a kid in my middle
school Theo lipsky who I was like that's
like and he was shout out he had like he
had glasses and he was like different
and he was kind of cute and I was like
you know what Theo's gotta going on and
that was my you know how like you think
of a name through the lens of the people
you know
with that name so I just thought of Theo
as like the sophisticated name
and when I named the otheo and I loved
it after like a year I do wish that I
had saved it for like my own child but
now everyone's doing it yeah so I don't
even know if I had a child right now if
I would take the name yeah I wonder like
if there's a correlation between like
like what the popular dog name list is
in popular human names and like if
one precedes the other
perhaps because here are the top girl
dog names one Luna
I've never met a dog named Luna never to
Bella
classic classic but also a nice human
name
yes three Daisy
cute for Lucy Lucy Lucy Apple juicy I
like the name Lucy five Willow
okay classic we know a willowed costumes
at all good six penny
never heard of it like for a dog yeah
seven Sadie
adorable eight Maggie
okay I'm with Magnolia fall under that
one no and that's not my favorite name
I think I'm Maggie Gyllenhaal nine Rosie
that's a cute name I like that name too
ten Ruby
cute well that's like fairly obvious
because it's a color yeah but it's also
a very popular girl name right now yeah
so that's what people are naming their
dogs I didn't see a Bryce I didn't see a
strise I didn't see a Thrice
I didn't see a price
you know what that is disgusting yeah
but you know what maybe they're
influenced it's like on a time delay
yeah maybe next year maybe next year
honestly I feel like people might
certainly mean their dogs Bruno because
of Encanto
yes I don't disagree so that's exciting
we don't talk about Streisand no no
um well the show's not over because
thanks to my negligence we have deer
toasters today our weekly advice segment
that usually happens on Wednesdays but
again negligence
um if you ever want to write in it's
deertoesters gmail.com we got so many
submissions after yesterday's episode so
you know what everything happens for a
reason because now we have a fresh batch
um and dear toasters is brought to you
by Jackie's favorite Babel one of the
most exciting things about a new year is
that you have no idea what Adventures
are in store from you from new travel
experiences to new jobs or picking up
new skills there's no better way to
prepare for 2023 than by learning a new
language with Babel Babel is the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions and thanks
to Babel's addictively fun and easy
bite-sized language lessons you can feel
confident no matter where the New Year
takes you takes you so if you have any
trips coming up like I um went to Italy
a little while ago and I did download
Babel a few weeks before just to
familiarize myself with like the basics
because I feel like traveling to a
country where you don't know a lick of
the language it's not a really fun way
to travel and it's not like the safest
thing so just knowing you know the
basics of like bathroom right left like
I just think it's really helpful and
it's also really fun it's a great thing
to do as an adult like a hobby to pick
up to expand your horizons of your mind
it's great for you it's great if you're
traveling it's great if it's just like
an interest of yours
and Babel's easy because you only need
10 minutes to complete a lesson you can
start having real life conversations in
a new language in as little as three
weeks you could choose from 14 different
languages Spanish German French and
their speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent start your language learning
Journey today with Babel right now get
up to 55 off your subscription when you
go to babble.com toast that's a babble
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash toast for up to 55
off your subscription Babble language
for life again that link is babel.com T
oh a s t
um all right are you ready for deer
toasters I'm excited to to get into it
ready
so first up Jackson mclared love you
girlies OG breather my sister mom and I
have been listening for years we feel
like you guys are our sisters at this
point
anywho I need major major advice here
long story short I've been interviewing
for a new job in social media marketing
I made it through four rounds of
interviews with a very well-known
non-profit social media director Kim
Gwyneth Jessica Alba Kristen Bell are
all heavily involved it's like a really
legit organization okay I know what it
is
oh oh I know what it is too
I spent six hours on a marketing project
for my last round of interviews I put
together a 12 slide deck I met with the
CEO with the co-ceos I pitched them at
least 15 amazing ideas for social media
and I made them a whole content calendar
well after all that they ghosted me I
sent three follow-up emails and nothing
I followed them on Instagram I started
to see them using my [__] ideas from
my interviews my pitches my ideas I'm so
upset it's all over their social media I
don't know what to do do I send them a
skating email being like hi what the
[__] do I say nothing help they continue
to use my ideas for my interview and I
don't know what to do it breaks my heart
every time I see it love I taken
advantage
of toaster you can sue
yeah yeah I mean it's it's are we going
to be out here suing a non-profit yeah
because they're acting for profit and if
it's the one that I'm thinking of they
have a ton of money and they're not
acting in a generous charitable way
stealing ideas from a young creator
I also feel like a way to get your um I
hate when like I think when people do
this it's like so tacky but you can make
like a tick tock calling a Revenge talk
those those talks always go viral and
they always get the brand or whoever
like the accused party is they always
get them to respond the only thing is
they might respond but they're not going
to now hire you which is like a winner
which is they're not hiring her anyway
no I know but you're not going to get
like any money or anything whereas like
they stole your ideas you are owed money
I think like it's expensive to Sue and
it's very time consuming and so if you
don't want to do that that's like what
you should do is get a lawyer but if you
don't want to do that and you just want
like revenge and you just want like
acknowledgment then you could do a
Revenge talk that's not the worst idea I
would also just triple check because I
think a lot of the time when people
think other people steal their ideas or
copy them it's like a very not
unoriginal but like obvious idea it's
like the toast you guys should go on
tour like yeah we should but like yeah
is that a crazy original thought that
like only only one person could have
that's so true I would just triple check
that like maybe ask around be like is
this like a dumb thing yeah like show
all of the examples and see what people
say because like if I was on you know if
I was me I'm just doing my job and I
didn't know this story and then I see
this Tick Tock like I'm gonna be looking
really closely at what these ideas are
make sure there can't be holes poked in
your revenge talk or your lawsuit yeah
agreed but once you have like full proof
like these are my hella original very
specific ideas that are being stolen
either sue if you're looking for money
and by the way like you might be able to
get like a lawyer pro bono because this
would be like a high profile case
um or blow them up on Tick Tock or you
should also do like a little bit of
research online to see if other people
have complained about like experiences
with this company glass door glass door
yeah like either former employees I mean
you could always find people who have
like some [__] to say but like is this
something that is a pattern for them
yeah
that's a good call too just yeah
okay we've got a little Stagecoach drama
howdy Jackson Claude I've been dating my
boyfriend for two years and we've been
living together for one year lately I
just don't think he's the guy for me and
I've been planning on breaking up with
him and moving out in the next couple of
months he randomly out of the blue
surprised me with Stagecoach tickets
flights and an Airbnb everything already
paid for can I in good conscious go on
this trip thank you and advice thank you
in advance of the vice and advice and I
promise to update you sincerely a
confused country toaster so you want to
go on the trip but you think it's like
bad she's gonna break up with him and
now she's like should I just wait till
after Stagecoach to break up with him so
I can get this free trip no not even
because it's like morally corrupt to
take the free trip because it's also
like kind of sad to then leave him
hanging with it all paid for but because
like I feel like when people want to
break up with someone they constantly
piss it off because it's like oh we have
you know this wedding coming up and then
after that like we had this trip plan
and like then it's three years and then
like you can't like there's always going
to be something and I don't think that's
a good a reason to stay in a
relationship like of course you want to
go to Stagecoach but do you really like
want to live with this person for four
more months until then no it if you want
to go to Stagecoach go take yourself
well I would also think an important
factor here in terms of context is his
financial situation like is this nothing
for him or is this a lot because he
could always take someone else
no but it's also way in advance like he
could get his money back for his Airbnb
and for his flights maybe not the
tickets but he could go or sell them for
a profit
yeah unless like he bought them for her
he doesn't like country music
stop it's so sad I agree like it's
really mean
it's just like
you can't put your life on hold for
Stagecoach
no and like you you can still go to
Stagecoach you could also
offer to buy the tickets buy it all off
of him
that's a good call he did all the work
why should you know you now plan another
trip yeah like break up with him and
when you guys are like sorting things
out be like I also I was thinking about
Stagecoach like I so appreciate that you
bought that for me I don't want to like
stick you with tickets and all this
stuff if you were wouldn't go with
someone else so like if you don't want
to keep all that like I will buy that
off of you that is a good plan I think
that's because you're doing the right
thing and you might get your tickets
yeah they're not free but you're still
going no what makes me sadder is to
think of like him stuck with all this
stuff he tried to do a nice thing and
like now he doesn't want to go he
doesn't have anyone to go with and who
wants to go and call Airbnb and get
refunds and sell your tickets on
Ticketmaster like that's he's she's
giving him work so like offer to take
that off his plate
yeah I love that love it
okay for third and final is [__]
weird Jackson Claude love you and need
you now my husband and I have been
living in my parents basement for a few
months while our house is under
construction it's not the most ideal
situation but my parents have been so
sweet my mom especially has been so
thoughtful done little things to make us
dinner constantly offering to run
errands for us she even noticed my
husband's shoes were worn out and she
bought him a new pair but one day my
husband overheard my mom on the phone
with her mom they were gossiping about
someone rather harshly he later told me
that he might not feel comfortable
having our future children be around her
because she talks bad about people I'll
be the first to admit that my family
does tend to gossip more than we ought
to but this seems a little bit dramatic
especially considering all the good
things my mom is doing do you agree that
this is a bit of an overreaction on his
part or is my moral compass just so
swayed by my gossiping tendencies that
maybe he's right what should I do please
put me in my place if need be thanks so
much girl you are not need to be put in
your place oh and by the Laurel High
Ground I'm surprised we could you could
even talk to him from how high up he's
standing he also he must be perfect he
must be a perfect pie is wonderful human
being that he would even think such a
thing first of all like calm down like
we're calm down we're women like we talk
and like for her to be talking to her
own mom like she's entitled to her
private thoughts like that's not gossip
she's not like going around to the
neighbors like talking to people stuff
like family in a safe space own house on
the phone
talking to her mom like get out of the
house then go go to invade someone
else's privacy and then judge what you
see them doing in private is actually
like a really [__] up condescending
thing to do especially it's not like she
was you know stabbing people in private
she was gossiping which is a rather
victimless crime so I think your husband
needs to take several seats and you
maybe should play this episode for him
being like why don't you worry about
things that are actually important yeah
like and and that you don't want yours
like bad examples that children might
see like yeah I would say that's maybe
000 on the list on the list
completely agree like of the things you
need to worry about in this day and age
that doesn't register right because
let's talk about what we know just from
this brief paragraph about your mom
otherwise is that she sounds extremely
generous letting you stay at her house
very thoughtful buying you new sneakers
you know very um caring offering to run
errands sounds like she has a lot of
amazing qualities and maybe gossiping
isn't her best quality but you know what
I find from that I find that she's human
because nobody's perfect right and yeah
your man is being really judgmental here
I I think you should play this episode
for him you do not need to be put in
your place but he must be an absolutely
perfect person yeah to be so critical of
something like that
yeah it's and then like to be so
dramatic like I don't feel comfortable
having my future children here first of
all you're thinking about something you
don't even have kids yeah like calm down
no and it's like but you're comfortable
enough to live up to mooch
you're comfortable enough to get some
free sneakers
literally like calm the [__] down dude
it's not that big of a deal yeah he just
needs to be read to filth and it should
be taken care of
perfectly put he just needs to be read
to filth and everything will be taken
care of like this isn't like red flag
just no
no this is just like husbands like being
dumb and dramatic it happens all the
time to millions of Americans and
dramatic
you're gonna be fine you're gonna be
fine
he might not be but you will be that
sounds like you have a great mom
uh a sweetheart I would love to gossip
with her that she knows everything
because one thing about me like I am
going to gossip I am not above gossip I
believe gossip is you know a part of an
integral part of any freedom of speech
is an exchange of information and if
there's a gossip sesh I will be joining
even if I don't know the people I'm like
give me background yeah yeah I'll be
joining but if I find things are getting
nasty and like yes I'm sitting with a
bunch of losers who are talking [__]
about like people who are trying
something yes I will leave it just
depends I agree there's two different
types of Gossip one is like an exchange
of information I think that's gossip and
then there's talking [__] where it's
like you're putting people down for just
like doing their best and like being
judgmental that's different yeah
but I still don't think I would refuse
to have my children around someone who
did that it's even the bad one is not
that bad yeah
but I don't think that's what she was
doing no just because like she bought
you shoes because she saw you guys were
worn like she's a nice person she's
obviously like a good-hearted human
being yeah
so that is our show that was dear
toasters again if you want to write in
it's deertoesters gmail.com we will
always keep your [__] Anonymous do not
worry
um and we'll do our best to help you out
and I think we help the girls out today
I think we do too I feel good about the
work we did here today at the toast I'm
glad we could talk through everything me
too
so that's our show thank you so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to know
everybody through Friday on YouTube so
if you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so on Spotify iTunes Stitch or
public radio iheartradiocastbox all the
places so every listen to podcast find
us the toast leave a five-star review
about a beautiful stunning and smart we
are hope you guys have an inkaya
Thursday you know what I need to do I
need to learn how to sign the outro
because I'm always here like doing my
doing like hand motions and I feel like
I should be doing signing it I feel like
if anybody is fluent in ASL like send
Jackie a video of the outro but then you
can't ever change it so let's do like
beautiful stunning and wickedly talented
okay
but before I do that I want to say this
is our final live episode of the week
tomorrow's episode will be up in the
morning it is a podcast and video
interview with somebody really exciting
we're gonna be announcing who the guest
is on our Instagram today so make sure
you're following us at the toast and you
check back in later to see who the guest
is
all the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the toast leave a five
star review about a beautiful stunning
and a wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have an Thursday we'll see you
tomorrow love ya bye
put put that tongue back in your mouth
nah